ce la fai a prendere il martello zio
prima che ecco perfetto No no madonna
mia quanto trash questa scena Santo
Iddio questa operazione è di lusso
prevede anche un taglio ai capelli
Questo è il cuore di Trump Oh cazzo è
quella è una collana che le regalo
sempre io
veramente siamo di nuovo su questa merda
Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono Favij ed oggi
siamo tornati su sorge un Simulator
Ragazzi allora era da una vita Ma
veramente da una vita che non facevo
questo video game considerando il fatto
che non mi ricordo come si muove la mano
ma mi ricordo che avevo Cristo nato che
la metà basta
Ciao
Perché mi si è appena suicidato
l'orologio da polso
ho voluto rigiocare a Surgeon Simulator
perché hanno inserito una nuova modalità
che è quella di
che è successo
Ah ok È già parti niente È già partita
hanno inserito la nuova modalità che
consiste nell'operare Donald Trump giuro
Cioè tu devi operare Donald Trump su
Sergio non Simulator gli devi fare un
trapianto di cuore a Donald Trump Nel
senso che io gli devo trapiantare un
cuore d'oro o un cuore di pietra ok
Quindi io gli devo levare il cuore che
c'ha e mettergli un cuore un cuore di di
Guarda che bello Trump guardate le
scritte in basso Breaking news della
serie proprio stanno operando Donald
Trump sarà il dottore in grado di
salvargli la vita è ovvio mica come sono
professionale io ti ho preso il naso
vuoi avere un'anteprima del mio voto per
le lezioni caro Trump Ah ah ah
vabbè eh basta eh accendiamo di capire
perché c'è un regalo perché c'è una
bistecca qual è il motivo Va bene signor
Trump Siccome questa qua è una sala
operatoria molto di lusso per lei
l'abbiamo riservato una bella bistecca
di media cottura come lei preferisce
Buon appetito allora vediamo di fare
questo trapianto come si deve posso
usare un po' Maroc d'oro perché è d'oro
Ah perché lui è Donald Trump giusto le
cose devono essere di lusso devo devo
incidere Ecco no de devo cazzo Ok
perfetto effettuato questa operazione
con la massima sensibilità l'ha sentito
niente perfetto Ecco ragazzi e questo ve
lo spiega il dottor Faby se il paziente
non risponde Quando fate delle domande
significa che indubbiamente sta bene
sennò ve lo direbbe questo qua è suo Ma
se lo vendo su eBay ci fa sui Big Money
c'è anche il prezzo dell'operazione
836.000 dollari alla Madonna se glielo
spalmo in faccia vale di più che cazzo è
vodka Trump Oh cazzo no no scherzavo
signor Trump Ecco bravo Apra la bocca
perfetto perfetto quanto trash questa
scena Santo di Dio Boh Quando ha sentito
il profumo di vodka spalancato alla
bocca Vabbè Eh in tutto questo sta
morendo Trump Quindi io direi è la
Madonna che cos'è ma perché
E va bene questa operazione di lusso
prevede anche un taglio ai capelli
quindi stia tranquillo si rilassi che
procedo
Ah non vorreste vedere questa cosa
Quindi non ve la faccio vedere Vabbè
ragazzi proviamo a farlo serio adesso se
non lo so adesso riesco perché da una
vita che sono fuori allenamento con
Sergio già era difficile ai tempi senti
e come il bambino col ciuccio prendi
quello che vuoi Chi è il martello per
scassare non c'è più niente Ah eccolo
Guarda che presa Bella solida che c'ho
ce la fai a prendere il martello zio
prima che ecco perfetto No no Madonna
mia che deficiente posso usare questo
per spaccargli le ossa o no Ah sì sì
posso Ok ce l'ho fatta Ragazzi sto
togliendo non so neanche come ma
veramente Esistono dei laser Oddio sono
riuscito No credo di aver ucciso
l'infermiera nell'altra sala ragazzi
sono sicuro non c'è la siringa per
fermare le Eccola questa qua sarebbe la
siringa rigorosamente con l'ago d'oro
perché sennò non andava bene per fermare
le emorragia ok
Ma no Ma cazzo Me l'ha aumentata Ma come
Ma non è vero e non funziona è tarocca
il signor Trump non funziona Lago d'Oro
non serve a un cazzo in teoria doveva
fermare l'emorragia non aumentarla Vabbè
non importa proviamoci lo stesso Vai
Devo fare veloce signor Trump Mi
dispiace se devo buttare i suoi organi
che verranno un sacco di soldi perché la
mano mi si rimpicciolita non importa vai
vai veloce prendi sto [ __ ] Thor per
forza crepare sto cristiano Eh vabbè
[ __ ] nel frattempo prima che crepi
mi prendo il fegato
Oh non riesco a prendere le cose li
mortacci sua eh Li mortacci veramente
crepato questo se mi facessi il favore
Oh Perfetto Sì ma sto Madonna quanto sei
monco Oh minchia ma era difficile come
lo stai temendo operazione chirurgica
della massima importanza tiene il
martello così come se fosse una clip
1.600 millilitri di sangue velocissimo
prendi sto allora che problemi c'hai
questo polmone frate qual è il problema
perché Oh minchia questo qua lo vendo al
doppio raga è in estraibile Anzi io e
annusa Perfetto Adesso rimuoviamo questo
coso che probabilmente è un Pokémon
Infermiera mi passi il telefono che devo
controllare se su Pokémon Go ci sono
Pokémon in questa stanza Ma come ha
fatto incastrarsi lì porca [ __ ] Oh
perfetto Tra l'altro mi spiegate con che
fisica sta tenendo sto coso Spiegami ce
l'abbiamo fatta Vai veloce in CD Bravo
zio Che gioia che mi dai perfetto Vai
perfetto Oh no l'orologio Eh la live È
una feature Cioè glielo regalo fa parte
dell'opera persone se non mi muovo
ragazzi Questo mischia Perfetto ce l'ho
fatta devo solo rimpiazzarlo questo è il
cuore di Trump Oh cazzo E quella è una
collana che le regalo sempre io Apri
porca [ __ ] ce l'ho fatta e Allora
prendiamo il cuore d'oro ok ci siamo
posizioniamolo veloce veloce
perché ci sta musica di sottofondo
spiegatemi anche io faccio using
townswell Medical Center Hospital 3
minuti e 24 di operazioni Beh perfetto
raga continuiamo eh Comunque raga è la
cosa più trash ma veramente più trash
che io abbia mai fatto in sto gioco eh È
bellissimo Va bene Mi fa piacere che sto
gioco ogni tanto se ne esca queste
cagate comunque ragazzuoli Spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto Spero sia stato di
lezione per tutti quanti voi perché
ovviamente questo qua è una lezione di
di chirurgia avanzata Se avete bisogno
di altri tutorial Guardate i miei primi
video su saggio in Simulator che
esplicano come effettuare un vero
trapianto di cuore di reni
di Pokémon Spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto e che cosa vi sia piaciuto
lasciate un commento e un mi piace anche
la pagina di Facebook come nei video a
tornare in descrizione Ciao sono
iscritti iscrivetevi ci vediamo al
prossimo video bella ragazzi e bella
Tramp sarà sicuramente contentissimo Ma
[ __ ]